بالامس فعلا كانت التغطيه لبعض
المسافرين المغادرين من الخرطوم ربما الى
ولايات اخرى وربما خارج السودان اليوم
وكانت عدد من الشكاوى حول نفاذ المواد
الغذائيه والمواد التموينيه وهو ما يغلق
الكثيرين
وتشير بعض المعلومات الى ان هذه المواد
الغذائيه ربما
تنفذ او لا لا تكفي لمده اسبوع وما يكون
مسار يعني
مثال
لقلق الكثيرين انا في احد المحاله
التجاريه وعاده كثير من المحال التجاريه
يعني في هذا التوقيت تكون مغلقه وجدنا هذا
المحل يفتح ابوابه للمشترين
ونود ان نقرا سويا ونتعرف ايضا على الحركه
الشرائيه للنزعه المواد الغذائيه سنتعرف
من خلال الاستاذ عاصم الذي هو صاحب هذا
المحل مرحبا استاذ عاصم الله يسلمك الله
يبارك بدايه بتعمل بشكل كامل ولا جزئي
والله في الحقيقه من بدت الاحداث نحن
سرحنا كل الموظفات
وبنشتغل الان بشباب قله معظمهم كلهم مسافر
للعيد او بسبب الازمه ونحن يعني
بنشتغل تحت ظروف صعبه جدا ندره في المواد
الغذائيه
والموردين والشركات اللي هي كلها بتاعتك
مشتقات الالبان وكلها ما موجوده يعني
حاليا كلنا الموجود في المخازن نحن كله
جبناه
وخطيناه
لكل المواطنين فتحنا ابوابنا واقفين معاهم
يعني بنشتغل كيف الاقبال الحركه الشرائيه
للناس والله كان الشراء في بدايه الازمه
كان بهلع شديد جدا
وخوف وطبعا كان اثناء القصف والضرب
والرصاص الناس كان بتجي تشتري في ساعه
الهدنه
والمواد شنو اقبالن عليها والله ما في
حاجه في كل الاشياء كل المواد الغذائيه
الناس دي اخذتها ما عدا المنظفات والحاجات
اللي هي لها علاقه
هل في بعض الغلاء للاسعار ولا هي كما هي
والله بالنسبه للخضروات هي شويه في ارتفاع
في الاسعار الخضروات واللحوم
يعني بعض اللي هو الفراخ البيض دي الحاجات
القدر توصلتنا وصلتنا باسعار زايده يعني
لكن باقي مواطن اللي هي موجوده في المخازن
وفي نفس الازرار نحن
بنبيع على الجمهور يعني انتم كاصحاب محل
مناشرتنا لكل
اصحاب المحلات انا بدعوه منه يفتحوا
محلاتهم للجمهور يعني
والموردين برضو اللي هم شركات الالبان
ومشتقاتها
وكل الشركات اللي هي بتاعه المواد
الغذائيه انها هي يعني تورد المواد والناس
كلها تنزل دوامها عادي يعني شغالين ولله
الحمد كل الناس دي معانا هنا وبتقضي في
حاجاته وما في حاجه يعني انا يعني بقول
لهم انه الهلع والخوف ده
وان شاء الله كل الامور يعني
يصير بصوره طيبه يعني ايضا معنا صوت احد
المواطنين مرحبا
اولا احيي قناه الحدث على اهتمام الدائم
بقضايا السودان
ونسال الله ان يرفع هذه الازمه عن الشعب
السوداني حقيقه هذه كارثه
احلت بالشعب السوداني
والملاحظ هذه الايام ان معظم المواطنين قد
هجروا
منازلهم الى الولايات والارياف بسبب
الظروف الامنيه
ونتيجه لذلك كثير من اصحاب المحاله
التجاريه كذلك اغلقوا محالهم وذهبوا كذلك
الى الولايات حيث الامن الذي حدث بعد ذلك
ان هنالك قليل من المحاله التجاريه هي
التي تعمل
هذه المحال بكل مواطن سنون الالبين قصك
حاليا في البيت من مواد غذائيه وتنمويه
والله
المواد التموينيه
الاشكال في المواد التموينيه انها غير
متوفره بالحد الكافي بسبب ان ان كثير من
المحاله التجاريه اغلقت ابوابها وبالتالي
المواطن يعاني في البحث والوصول الى
المرحله التجاريه هذا اولا الامر نعم
الاسعار بكل اسف تضاعفت اضعافا مضاعفه
وهذا امر سيء حقيقه لانه
المطلوب في مساحات هذه الظروف ونحن كشعب
سوداني شعب معهود عندنا التضامن ان يكون
العكس تماما ان يكون هناك تخفيف على
المواطنين بتخفيض الاسعار هذه نقطه
الملاحظ كذلك غياب تام حقيقه
لوكالات العون الانساني للمواطنين هناك في
المياه حقيقتين يعني هنالك سحب في المواد
التموينيه هنالك سحب الادويه معظم
المستشفيات قد تضررت وبالتالي في مثل هذه
الظروف كان المطلوب ان تكون هنالك مراكز
صحيه في الاحياء على الاقل يستفاد من
الكادر الطبي الموجود في كل حي وكذا مواقع
للمواد التنوينيه نتمنى ان حقيقه يعني
وكاله العون الانساني تسهم في هذا ولكم
التحيه والتقدير الجميع اذا هي اصوات
المواطن السوداني ايضا شح المواد
التموينيه وبعض الارفف تبدو خاليه تماما
يعني بعض الارفف نفذت منها هذه المواد
وصعوبه استيراده هم فقط
يستوردون من المخازن ايضا هنا بعض الارفف
هنا الارز
وهنالك ارفف فارغه تماما
وبالتالي هي شكاوى المواطن السوداني من شح
هذه المواد ومن الخوف والقلق من نفاذها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات